für den inhalt dieses spots sind alle
parteien verantwortlich
[Musik]
wegen gefährlichem fall terror einbrüche
leere bierdosen und die politik druck
nichts steht sicherheit unter der
eingebrochenen belassen
wirklich alle arschlöcher häuser gewinn
auf der polizeiwache im bug der
gefährdeten arten steht gleich neben
schwabe der deutschen politik praktisch
wahl war lecker wie kommt vom essen zu
cdu die cdu jedenfalls die vielmehr vor
dem 2 dann mach doch ihr seid eine
regierung die spd sagt nur reiche können
sich geändert hat doch ihr seiner
regierung hat noch mehr videoüberwachung
da sind sich alle einig
[Musik]
ich sage immer was viele gut finden ist
meistens scheiße bayern münchen
also müsste ausdrücken seht ihr das
nicht mehr geschieden verbrechen wurde
was denn ein flüchtlingsrat dass unsere
deutschen haus ganzen weg da muss man
doch was machen die ganze gelaber von
mehr sicherheit und dann keine antwort
habe ich wenig geschlafen
denn schon machen vielleicht ja doch
wählen dann bricht alles genial
und die haben mich so den traktor page
und keiner und hannelore in nrw warum
wir die flasche warum machen können wie
nichtwähler
wenn wir mehr gehen für den inhalt
dieses spots sind alle parteien
verantwortlich